pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici donc en compte en circulation en
réalité le nouveau en le franc lourd
monnaies sonnantes et trébuchantes qui
fera bonne figure aux côtés du franc
suisse du mark allemand et de toutes les
monnaies qu'on pouvait dire hier à
change au il succède au front bonaparte
créé en 1803 et qui aura duré cent
cinquante sept ans
ce bon vieux eu des malheurs à la fin de
sa vie la guerre de 14 en avait fait un
jeton ensuite il était devenu le franc
quatre sous puis 17 remaniements
successifs avec la guerre et
l'occupation l'avait amenuisé jusqu'à ne
plus valoir qu' environ un demi centime
il est mort de construction le voici
donc avec un nouveau franc un vrai fan
de centimes qui valent nos sans
frontières
bien sûr ce n'est plus tout à fait le
front de bonaparte les fleuves ne
retourne pas à leurs sources et les
mener pas davantage avec ses 180 mg d'or
fin il est loin des 290 de son devancier
ne représente plus que 62% des trois
cinquièmes environ c'est pour cela qu'on
ne pourra pas rendre aux hommes de 60
ans les prix de leurs enfants et c'est
avec une certaine mélancolie qu'ils
continueront à regarder des chiffres
mort dans les brouillards du sud lit on
enrage n'ira pas moins de quelques
lustres mais de façon inégale
le pyjama très fiers nous ramène à 14
mai le porte monnaie tout cuir de nous
rend que 1926 on va le voir le veston au
prix de 1930 la chemise à celui de 28 et
le chou comme en 26
car c'est assez palier que le franc
lourd nous ramène les prix ont augmenté
depuis 14
celle à qui mais il ya des cas où la
machine se renverse les progrès des
techniques et les conquêtes du
machiniste faut que les produits
industriels ont diminué par rapport au
passé
l'automobile par exemple pour un prix
sensiblement égal quelle différence
entre la voiture d'aujourd'hui et le
bolide de 1919
tout de même on va voir la vie avec des
jus rajeunie par exemple à l'énoncé des
problèmes la décimale qui ont fait
passer à nos enfances de si joyeuse
soirée
sûrement on aura des déconvenues combien
d'entre nous vont se sentir frustré de
n'être plus millionnaire et qu'il
n'était pas aujourd'hui était bien sûr
de l'être demain
[Musique]
mais d'autre part on va être
heureusement surpris des nouvelles de
son percepteur
m
elle aura recommencé à dire il a
économisé sou par sou et aussi parce
c'est à dire que tout revient à sa place
et qu'il y a à nouveau moyen d'écrire
les mots solidité sécurité à venir et
c'est quelque chose vous savez
[Musique]
au moment où l'année commence dénoncé
face celui de fausto coppi qui fut le
plus grand champion cycliste et que
vient d'emporter à 40 ans une maladie
contractée en afrique où il était allé
courir avec le français raphaël
geminiani le tour de france avait vu par
deux fois triomphé le campionissimo là
ne s'arrêtait pas son palmarès plusieurs
fois vainqueur du tour d'italie
recordman du monde de leur champion du
monde de poursuite champion du monde sur
route copie rouleur-grimpeur sprinteur
était le coureur complet
et c'était aussi l'homme le plus simple
un autre nom albert camus qui recevait
voici deux ans à stockholm le prix nobel
de littérature
albert camus qui était dans le monde
l'une des grandes voix françaises a
trouvé la mort à 47 ans un accident
d'automobile a brisé la vie et l'oeuvre
de celui qui avait écrit la peste
l'étranger la chute mais s'il s'efface
aujourd'hui de l'actualité le nom
d'albert camus restera celui d'une
oeuvre
[Musique]
depuis le xviie siècle le quartier du
marais a subi bien des avatars à l'ombre
des autres demeures qui virent pressé
ninon de lenclos et la chaire marquise
de sévigné bruit maintenant un monde
d'artisans et de petits fabricants qui a
envahi les hôtels noble tomber en recul
mais il est toujours le quartier élus
des alchimistes d'hier devenus les
inventeurs de journée tout près de ce
qui fut l'antre de cagliostro un homme
fait de l'or aux risques d'incendié ce
quartier vénérable dans le petit deux
pièces qu'il occupe sur la cour monsieur
marathonians ne change tout de même pas
le plomb ville en or pur mais sur la
cuisinière ou madame marathonians fait
bouillir le poteau que cet inventeur son
complexe fabrique au moyen d'un alliage
secret leur bh qui possède la dureté
exceptionnelle d'un excellent tassier
ovale de révolution dans le monde de la
bijouterie de l'horlogerie et de
l'électronique
[Musique]
on parle même aux états unis d'en
recouvrir à titre de protection les
satellites artificiels
le premier jour de 1960 s'élever à alger
sur la cité de climat de france
complètement terminée et peupler ce
groupe architectural qui couvre 30
hectares et qui étale ses blocs autour
d'un marché à colonnes aussi vaste que
le palais royal de paris peut compter
parmi les ensembles urbains les plus
esthétiques du monde entier c'est
peut-on dire l'équivalent d'une ville de
la taille de chartres qui est née avec
ses commerces divers ou une population
de 30 mille habitants peut trouver à
s'approvisionne 4500 logements où sont
assurés les principes du confort moderne
sont aujourd'hui totalement équipé
chacun conservant ce souci
d'individualités qui refusent
l'uniformité en offrant les meilleures
conditions d'hygiène
beaucoup de villes peuvent envier à
alger le privilège de marché hardiment
dans la voie du progrès avec l'imac
france on peut reconnaître le plus vaste
effort engagé ici dans la bataille du
logement
[Musique]
la roue de secours passe en torrent de
des visiteurs en cas de choc brutal
voilà l'invention de monsieur jacques
gérin qui assure-t-il est capable de
vous sauver la vie
disposés à l'avant en guise de pare
chocs elle se met en mouvement sur
l'obstacle et en la dédiant empêche la
voiture d'accentuer la violence de la
collision
bonne idée
[Musique]
en cas de dégonflage semin studio à
double prise vous permettra de parer à
tout danger en rendant à votre pneu une
élasticité suffisante sans avoir besoin
de changer votre roue bien entendu il
n'est pas recommandé de s'adresser aux
pneus d'une voiture voisine en
stationnement mais plutôt à votre propre
roue de secours
la méthode est la même mais l'honnêteté
sauvegarder
[Musique]
à notre époque de stationnement
réglementé les contraventions pleure un
malin d'outre-rhin il ya trouvé
l'accommodement rêver suivez plutôt sa
démonstration
[Musique]
et voilà
mais au look que dans l'armée le
ministre l'a décidé le calot va
disparaître mais auparavant fernand
raynaud a bien voulu nous en démontrer
les ressources réglementaire et
insoupçonnée et certains regretteront ce
cas l'eau qu'il est sait si bien
s'exprimer les personnalités les plus
marquées comme les plus indécis
[Musique]
ne l'avait-on pas préférer aux cadeaux à
pointe de nos pères qui savait pourtant
lui donner en dépit de la consigne
menaçante
un air de suprême élégance désormais la
troupe portera le béret mais sera ce le
verrez de chasseurs alpins et celui de
parachutistes le portera tombe à plat
façon tarte
ou sur l'oreille style joyeux lurons en
tout cas fort probablement ainsi même
par moins 10
[Musique]
bien sûr tous les espoirs sont permis
c'est sans doute pourquoi
fernand raynaud s'ils étaient un peu
perdus mais soyons sans crainte le
règlement y mettra bon ordre et le béret
ne fera qu'ajouter au prestige de
l'uniforme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]